نحن على مشارك سوق هو الوحيد المتبقي في
محافظه خانيونس بعد حالات النزوح التي تمت
وعمليات التوغو التي قامت بها قوات
الاحتلال في مناطق مختلفه من المحافظه هذا
السوق هو سوق الظهره مليء
بالمبتعثين
شويه رز تع وكاله ماشي فيهم ورزش طحين
مستنى لسه ي الخمسه والاربعه
بمش عارفه ايش حاطه ميه على النار بقولش
تعملي غدا لاولادك مش لاقي حاجه امالنا
ميه ليه ه حمم فيها مش لاقي اكل مش لاقي
طعم ادها الظروف
صعبه
[تصفيق]
الاسعار غاليه جدا يعني الاشي مضاعف اضعاف
يعني حتى يعني كيلو الملح اللي بقى بشيكل
يوم 18 شيكل الناس يعني من وين معها مصار
الناس طالعه شارده ونازح من هناك معهاش
فلوس نسبت عننا ص جدا افتش على الخضره في
موجوده مش موجوده والخضره غاليه جدا مثلا
ك البندوره انا ممكن اشتريها بشوف غيري
بشتري نس كيرو حبتين او ثلاثه بقوللك وقت
اليوم في غير الثاني مشح يشتريها نفس
العمليه كي باذنجان ب 12 شيكل جريمه كبرى
انا واحد من الناس عندي 11 نفر مش قادر
اشتريها اله يا معلم اكترا السوق
بالمواطنين لا يعني انهم جاؤوا كلهم
ليشتروا من هذا السوق بل كثير منهم
متفرجين هذه واحده من معاناه اهالي قطاع
غزه في ظل الحصار المفروض عليه وكذلك
الحرب المدمره والدام على اهالي القطاع
لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر خان يونس
جنوب قطاع غزه